大家好我是星索首先非常感谢大家在直播间观看另外也感谢T顾沙龙早有些警察组织的这些系列活动非常有意义另外还是要感谢我们协议团队 客户团队对我的支持因为作为一线开发有机会参与到这个直播来是非常棒的谢谢团队对我的支持首先
做一個自我的介紹我是16年畢業畢業於華盛頓科技大學然後就在摩摩街工作然後19年呢入職了閒語之後一直在閒語做一些開發的工作主要呢從一開始的消息的腐蠟的話再到想企業的維護再到發布都一直在做腐蠟的開發另外呢在業務之餘其實也是幾個比較重要的一個腐蠟的中間界的一個作者
比如说我们前年也对外分享过的PowerScorpView滚动容器这个有点像我们Native或者比如说CollectionView或者NasacView这种当时主要是去解决一些业务上的比如说曝光比如说一些瀑布流这种能力去做的事情另外像去年底也对外分享过PowerImaging图片库是主要是Flat的图片库充分利用Native
SDK的一個能力最後一個是我們近期做的一個非常有意思的一個LAT的一個主題鍵叫MURROR它是一個縫紋編輯器今天我主要還是跟大家介紹一下ALL INVENTING圖編庫如果時間來得及的話我再給大家簡單講一下MURROR縫紋編輯器好那我們現在就開始吧首先說到圖編庫我們
知道Flat有自己的原生的图片库那么我们为什么要再做一个power image首先大家对native图片库熟悉的人知道做到后面其实一张图片展示在屏幕上那么我们会根据这个图片的大小就是view的大小去请求不同基督的CNN的链接进行加载这样有个好处我们不是请求原图那么根据
是的 原来请不同分辨率的图片那么是那个文件比较小所以这个呢在native那边是比较成熟的flutter 这边没那可能不要做的话flutter 要做一张其实成本还是比较高另外呢像特定格式的解码呃之前不知道大家有没有了解到过hgic格式呃在某个版本之前呢flutter 其实是没办法解码hgic的到某个版本之后才支持支持一个case啊
像HIC這種壓縮率比較高的那文件大小進一步又變小那整個的文件的下載的成功率及Decode的速度都會變快用戶能看到圖片的速度也會更快這也是一個例子那比如說我們集團可能最近也在研究的AVIF隔時能不能肯定又不能解碼但對於Native的圖片庫來說它是很快就能支持的第三個呢
就是靜态资源的问题这也是一个老问题了一般我们Native的靜态资源Flat这边是访问不到的假如说一张图我两边都要用到那可能是反两分这对包大小其实是不胜利如果你的用户特别多的话其实是浪费了用户特别多的空间举这三个例子其实也想说明一个我们Native既然有一个成熟的图片库那Flat这边最好直接用
这是第一点第二点我们在PowerImage之前实际上协用这边做了一个图片库我们内部叫它IFImage这个是完全基于Texture去做的基于Texture的方案实际上有些缺点稍后我也会讲一下这次我们在做PowerImage的时候实际上是利用了FFI的能力去来跟Texture进行一个双方案的优势步步
第三点这一点也很重要就是贴合flutter原生的img设计要和原生的img共同使用imgcatch就是flutter这边的图片缓存像我们原来的ifimg可能是根据页面站自己去管理的图片的生命周期但是imgcatch还是存在的只不过我们把预值给它调得比较低比如说30兆这种
在我们平时的业务开发里面实际上有些同学他可能还是会使用原生的Img去加载图片这就导致了他这个图可能是低频的图片但长期站在ImgCatch里实际上是对这个内存的浪费所以说我们这次做PowerImg实际上就是想和原生的Img一起来用ImgCatch这样的话对catch的利用率就会比较高更有意义一点这个说完了我们讲
講一下PowerImage的大致的能力特點剛才說到Tactile有什麼問題呢就是Flat這邊其實拿不到UI.Image很多場景下可能有同學需要這個UI.Image去做一些圖片的處理這個時候FFI的能力就體現出來所以我們有個能力就是根據參數來加在UI.Image的能力這個參數實際上就是FFI的請求的渲染方式第二個這是圖片的預加在能力
当我们在对页面做性能优化的时候可能会提前去请求一些图片的数据等到加载的时候可能可以很快的加载出来第三个这是模拟器这个问题呢实际上在某个flat版本之前通过tacture来渲染的图片实际上在ROS模拟器上是展示不出来的这个通过FFI我们就可以规避掉这个问题因为在模拟器上展示不出来很多同学他喜欢用模拟器
关于图片的所有都是白的实际上是没办法影响很影响第八个第四个呢就是我们刚才说的第三点啊对于imgcash的问题我们把新增文理法则与图片进行党通下一个呢其实就是一个自定义图片通类型通道这个也解决了业务自定义图片的诉求比如什么场景比如说咸鱼的那个相册在抛img之前咸鱼相册实际上
是自己走了一套tactile的逻辑的 实际上和ifimg是有些重复的地方而且呢 它这里也是没有经过flutter原生的img catch也就是说flutter原生的img catchifimg以及相则实际上它是各玩各的这里就是有些问题没有统一另外呢陶特这边也给我们贡献了一个动作的能力 稍后我也会介绍最后的一个监控出现的错误处
然後我也會說一下我首先介紹一下Tactile外界紋理的基本原理這裡分為兩部分部分是紋理的註冊另一部分是紋理的渲染這張圖也是以如此左下角的地址大家也可以去看一下首先先講一下這個顏色這紅色的部分其實就用我們類似要做的事情然後黃色的部分是flat引擎對應的部分首先講一下紋理的註冊
以RS为例我们需要实现一个flutter texture协议的一个类这个类的核心的方法就是 copypixel buffer打过一个 cvpixel buffer wrap我们把这个注册给flutter texture registry之后它会给我们一个这个文理对应的ID我们拿到这个ID之后通过桥到flutter那边flutter那边呢拿到这个ID实际上就用acture那个危机的进行展示就可以了
那渲染这边呢实际上Tactile这个iTactile就危机什么最终探索的是一个Tactile LayerTactile Layer要的参数也是一个ID引擎拿了这个ID实际上就会去到那个flat Tactile里去找到刚才注册进来的Tactile然后会执行CopyPixelBuffer方法那CopyPixelBuffer方法反过来一个StevyPixelBufferRef引擎再去通过是PixelBufferRef再去生成对应OpenGL的文理
这里之前也有给我讨论这里会不会IP一个新的内存但实际上是没有的它在它它实际上指向的还是拷费出来的那个CVPX8把活的那个内存内存地址段对具体大家也可以看一下引用的这里然后右下角就是Lutter这边对应的微机的使用实际上required的Tactile ID
刚才我们核心是要和原生结合吗?那我们再看一下原生的原理是什么我们以一个网络图为例我们给img.network传个UIL实际上在构造函数的地方会生成一个network img provider这个img state让它夹载的时候img provider实际上就以自己为key到img cache里面去找有没有我们的命中
假如说命中的话 实际上就会通知emiss进刷新刷新的时候它会去build的什么呢其实就是去拿到加载回来的uidimg去build the rawimg这个大家可以去研码看一下 假如说没有命中的话那么这个时候就去加载加载回来之后 实际上emiss catch里面有三个list一个是panning image list另外一个cache还有一个living image list
未来之后会把这个img-cache从panelimg-cache里面移出来放在cache里面去做一个更新之后呢会再次会通知那个img-state进去刷新其实整个的核心我们可以看到两个点一个是ur.img-cacheur.img-cache就是拿着去实际去build the rawimg-cache用的另外一个核心的是img-cacheimg-cache实际上也比较强依赖ur.img-cache
去做什么用呢是计算缓缩的大小是的然后接下来如果Texture跟原生的结合需要有三个问题需要解决第一个Image Widget需要UI点Image去Build rawImage这个而且对于原生来说它是没有扩展能力的那么我们该要怎么做呢我们可以自定Image来解决通过对外透出Image Build来让外国来决定实际实际Build是什么Widget
我们可以在这个时候去让它build the texture第二个问题img-catch依赖img-info的uidimg的宽高进行开始大小计算这里我们通过生存站位的img-info就是以一个像素点来进行输出然后在img-catch要它的宽高的地方给它return to the texture在用的宽高这样我们就可以完美规避了这个问题
第三个问题是tactile的native tactile的生命周期的问题在招媒体之前我们的图片其实是我们所管理的这种周期是根据一些页面站来进行的上那么无主果我们需要把这个事情交到Emicast的媒体由它外管理那么需要做刚才说到Emicast只有三个list那如果我们今天听到三个list释放这个Emicity的
实际试图就可以通出内容设计方案所以我们可以对InCAD进行一个小小的改放接着呢我们来讲一下Tactile方案FFI方案就是Tactile方案有些做不到的事情这个需要提到方案来互补这其中核心的其实就是UI.1的解决是反过提到的我们拿Native的内存例子长度的信息传队给法拉特测终于生成UI.1
整体代码也非常简单RS代码的也可以看到flutter这边拿到的crisis image info这个map实际上是native上面给的内存地址长度等信息然后也是调用了flutter ffi的方法然后最后 decode image from pixels拿到这个UID image最终呢我们当我们拿到UID image的时候再去让native释放最新的图片native上面的图片这里它是有一个问题就是它会
有一个内存拷贝他没有直接去用内提有那么多内存拷贝了就一个然后讲一下整体的架构应用层的话其实用户可以接触到的all img的接口跟原生的img是基本类似的比如说img.network我们这边叫all img.network新增了native loss就可以拿到native的警察资源另外支持一个扩展all img.network
比如说我要裤充相似类型那么这个Type比如叫iAlbum那我们这些有注册对应的loader就可以了但我们往下看PowerImage实际上会Build的两种Image这其实是一个封装比如说TextureBuild的是TextureImageEternal就是FFI的Image它实际上做了什么事啊其实就是特殊的TextureImage它在这里刺激一了刚才上面说的CustomImageBuild
去让自己实际上去buildtactile这个位置再往下呢就是img-catchEST这实际上就是对img-catch的一个扩充嘛主要核心就是拿到三个类似的释放img的一个实际对tactileimg的那种实际上就是刚内影相复的一个站位然后只不过是在那个return宽高的时候返回了一个tactile的值分powerimg-loader实际上就是和
native那边打交道比如说发行球和监听他们那边回降然后我们再看一个native这边native这边其实核心就是接入方我需要注册每一个type类型的图片对应的对应的加载器为什么flag的powering机没有内置啊因为大家用的native的图片库实际上powering机是不知道的那你们只需要用加载玩回来给我UI的音乐节或者
EATMAP就可以了另外呢业务方与不需要关心这个图是通过Textual的还是通过FFI的我们内部会判断就是Flatten那边设置的渲染类型然后去不同的处理然后再讲一下动土的方案这是陶特陶特贡献共产国内的谈合作动土呢我们暂时只支持了文理的动土
整体的逻辑也比较简单Native load加载回来的图片首先你要判断它是一张静态图还是动作如果动作的话实际上就用我们工装的Multiform Imaging这个要入采用的参数实际上就是有多少张图片每张图片所对应的时间这样就可以然后我们会定时去刷Tacture唯一做的一个比较特别的看右上角的代码实际上
因为动图场景在我们业务中实际上没那么平凡那他就不会占emg开始我们在他释放的时候在emg那个wg的释放这个emg的时候我们会直接把他从emg开始里面移除出去这样就减少了native这边做的事情就不需要关注这个图比如说一放到开始的时候没有展示的时候我要回去刷新啊这个之类就比较简单
接着我们看一下性能其实之前我们在无章里发的是1.2的一个性能最近我们就测了一个2.5.3的这是在iPhone11 Pro上三百张网络图在一个listview中三队大概每一行每页面的话会有六行的样子我们把netv的cats设计成最大20个plot里面开始三张
大家可以看到两个FFI和Tacture对实际上因为Tacture用FFI有跟内存跑配它的帽子会比较高但是这三个三本章图书像没有特别大的图如果有特别大的图它的上限会更高一点我们现在默认是使用了Tacture的后续呢其实我们更倾向于整个方案切到FFI另外呢原生图件就是偷偷做一个事情就是大家如果能看到原码的话其实可以看到它在
img provider外面会包含score aware provider这个是做什么实际上就是来监听你的滚动假如你整个外面的容器滚动速度过快的话它会暂停去加的这张图这也是大家用原生可以尝试出来比如说滚动过快的时候那个图就来了所以就原生中的一个优化另外它会有个resize的过程这点在包含img里面实际上是有的开关的大家可以选择用或者不用另外呢
讲下去是单册的覆盖单册的话实际上我们因为当初做这个的时候就倾向于更加合理就是予以维护其实单册是非常重要的整个单册覆盖率还是非常高的另外呢讲一下依赖结构我们的图片的核心代码是抛卫阶另外是为了适配不同的复杂的版本我们抽出了单独类库叫抛卫阶EXT实际上里面就是阴蔑阶
就是刚才前面提到的当然两库都是non-safety的如何接入一个flot这边实际上就是这是unicastefq的一个计划另外呢是触触的时候是一个全局的渲染方式比如tapture和ffi还有些异常回家的采压率啊这些类的littl这边主要就是这个power engine load protocol协议注册到对应的类型就可以了
因为API层面的话,以Network为例,实际上就传递一个,它SRC就是URL,我们这边构造的时候会把它生成一个PowerImgProvide对应的Textual对应的Provide,比如说是文理。另外呢,你可以自定义一个Img框架,默认它是按照微极杂的框架来的。另外呢,一些自定义的场景比如相册,它可以自定一个ImgType,刚才讲到Network那边,
渡測不同类型的Type来进行一个加载器相册这边实际上可以自定一个音频架机iAlbum然后SRC呢实际上是传给Native Loader那边的一个参数比如说相册的Asset ID可以放在这个SRC里面那么Native那边就拿到就加了这张照片对然后这个相关链接呢实际上就是我们在做图编库的时候和官方的一些
一些交流吧其中有些pr和一些e-show大家可以参考一下然后呢啊时间还有一些简单介绍一下副文本呃文本呢最近在google flock festival哈利哈尔尔上海站上我们的同事光球也在有介绍过这里就简单介绍一下啊我们的副文本编辑咪娜是使用的slate协议和的协议呃我们内部几个同学呢就把它的原码呃
協議的話我們就不多說了看一下原生的協議原生協議比較簡單就是文本和選區還有一個就是帶輸入的一個問題協議的流轉呢其實做文本其實有很重要的點就是不然原生的實際是到哪天呢免去做一些文本的輸入的就是OS這邊是ur text input大家可以運營成形成裡面去看一下整體的邏輯就是我們拿edit的就是我們協議
搬账系统的AddedValue给div.netmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmdmd
大家可以看到而且現在線上有一個權量大家可以試一下第二個詳情詳情的展示也是用mode進行展示的比如說點進都是可以另外我們還在系統基礎上其實做了一個優化我們同時曾遇在這方面比如說那個放大鏡其實也是它來開發的大家在詳情也可以體驗這個應該可能是最近集成的如果沒有上線可能等下我們能上線就體驗到
最后一个是光标的情况这个也比较有意思那天我那边光标安卓OS可能不太一样OS实际上它会回家回来一个位置XY我们计算光标的位置就可以看这个光标移到哪里去了安卓那边起码是一个指定比如说网组网约整体今天讲下来就是两个一个是POWING MEETING老图拼空另外是没有封门兵器
也欢迎大家在体验的时候如果有问题也支持可以向我们反过来全力保护我们就可以前半部分我们分享就到这里好 谢谢大家